bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans mon
atelier cet atelier c'est le monde
d'anne charlotte ouest elle une mort pas
yann de 34 ans depuis 2013 s'est lancé
dans la couture sous les conseils de sa
maman elle-même couturière j'ai quand
même toujours et emmanuel chassé manuel
de manière globale mais pour moi je sais
pas la couture ça restait quelque chose
d'inaccessible je voyais voilà nommé sur
coup d'oeil me disais mais je peux pas
je n'y arriverai jamais quoi comme quoi
je pense que voilà on peut tous s'y
mettre c'est vraiment accessible à tous
aujourd'hui cette jeune maman essaie de
coudre tous les jours ou presque en
jongle entre sa vie de famille son
travail d'assistante sociale
sa passion lui permet de confectionner
un à deux vêtements par semaine grâce à
des tissus acheté sur internet ou au
marché le train je voulais un trench
jaune on voit là et je me suis dit
j'achèterai pas parce que je trouverai
pas la couleur qui me faut et voilà j'ai
trouvé ce tissu un petit peu jaune
orangé avec une jolie doublure en twill
de soie et voilà et je les adore tout
simplement c'est coloré c'est péché
et puis ces tendances parce que je pense
que john et c'est à la mode voilà pour
faire vivre ses aventures et partager
ses créations elle a décidé de créer un
blog baptisé le bazar d'anne charlotte
et de publier en moyenne quatre à cinq
articles par mois
la couturière enregistre sur la
plateforme environ 1000 visites par
semaine
je sais à quel point ça peut être utile
quand les filles me disent ah super
grâce à toi j'ai compris comment réussir
le vêtement
voilà comment aussi tailles et alliés
grand taille petit ce qui va ce qui va
pas quelques tubes conseil
bon je pense que oui le mon blog peut
être un support dead comme moi je me
serve aussi d autres blogs au final quoi
au delà de son blog anne-charlotte
défend sa passion à la télévision
candidate de l'émission cousu main
concours de couturiers amateurs à mort
d'asia n'a été retenu par m6 parmi plus
de 3000 personnes
j'aime bien les challenges je suis très
bonne je suis une très belle joueuse moi
c'est à dire que je me suis dis bah
voilà
peu importe si je reste jusqu'au bout ou
pas
j'ai envie de m'éclater et je me suis
éclaté après cette expérience retour à
la vie normale dans son atelier de
maurepas prochain challenge pour la
couturière transmettre le virus du
tricot et du point de croix à ses
enfants